una crisis humanitaria Es lo que
advierte el informe un remedio para la
fiebre carcelaria en El Salvador
realizado por el International crisis
Group sobre la crítica situación de las
cárceles del país el grave de
hacinamiento combinado con la negativa
del gobierno asumir la responsabilidad
de lo que ha salido mal desde muertes
bajo custodia hasta restos
injustificados podría alimentar las
tensiones en las cárceles dando lugar a
motines y fugas bukele ha dejado tras
las rejas a unas 54.000 personas
agravando la superpoblación carcelaria
Todo bajo el régimen de excepción
decretado en marzo que permitió
suspender los derechos constitucionales
para intentar contrarrestar la crisis de
violencia del país
el informe expone además los métodos
poco ortodoxos del presidente nayib
bukele para luchar contra la violencia
de las pandillas según crisis Group las
autoridades han reprimido
despiadadamente a pandilleros o a
personas vinculadas incluso a sin
relación con estas organizaciones
delictivas con el apoyo público al
régimen de excepción por las nubes
bukele parece estar convencido de haber
firmado la sentencia de muerte de las
tres principales pandillas del país y
rechaza ferozmente las críticas a sus
métodos la ong recomienda que para
frenar esta crisis es necesario
abordarla con un enfoque más humano y
Buscar que los pandilleros puedan
reincorporarse a la sociedad